[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
all right I prefer the thing but hello
Dody ad this is a comedy podcast about
death where me and my brother John
sometimes guests guests answer your
questions give you beasts advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon but maybe not AFC
Wimbledon today but you're so close you
could just go by and check well I mean
it's not like you have no idea about
sports that are like a big deal in your
country you probably do but this is I
don't to be clear have any idea about
sports that have our big deal in my
country but I have C woman isn't like
it's not like Manchester United yeah
that's just one of the things yeah it
stresses me out too much if being
involved with sports like it get because
like they always lose eventually like
it's just so extremely unlikely that
your team is gonna win all the way that
I like it's always gonna end up in
disappointment and except for that one
time when it doesn't in the next year it
will and that's how it works unless
you're the Yankees and then you win all
the time because you have all the money
oh well you know they're not problem I
hope they're not angry I hope that they
just have a different opinion and I
respect their different opinion how are
how are you doing dirty doing I kind of
like my past self was just very an
empathetic I went here you go here's
everything you can handle it
and now I'm done i well when you when
you said yes to doing this podcast I
said never mind I know how busy you are
let this be the thing that you don't do
but you did it anyway
because I wanted to because I enjoyed
them and also because I was meant to be
done with a lot of big things so I was
like I'll be in my free time but I see a
space right calendar and I fill it and
then I'm like why why would I do that
but I enjoy it say yeah I know I know I
do the same thing and and I have taken
on too much as well but the recording of
dear Hank and John is one of the things
that I look forward to throughout the
week and and whenever I see it on my
calendar the next day I'm like oh thank
goodness that would be a nice hour of
hanging out with either my brother or
someone else I'd like and and it doesn't
feel like work which is why I do it I
cannot believe the amount of things that
you take on it's unbelievable I was
listening to one of these and you were
just listing everything that you do and
it was just like what so much well I
mean I like I think you do more than I
do I just have more help Mike my so so
maybe this should be like some like
group therapy time like how do you what
do you need to get past this difficult
time where your former itself has been
an uptick to your current self what's
what services what humans what help
because like it's out there and it can
be it can be very hard once you're busy
to fix your busyness because you're too
busy to put any time everyone's always
like just say no and like it's okay to
say no you need to prioritize your time
and it's like that's all very well but
when I'm in the point when it's
happening and I haven't done that now
what you just have to yeah it's not like
you can not like you're gonna hire an
assistant in the moments when when
you're working 80 hours a week because
hiring an assistant takes time exactly
like you have to yeah but these are all
lovely problems to have do you do you
want to know another lovely problem to
have Dody is that when when you signed
in to the podcast questions document
where we've got all our questions yeah
you weren't logged in
so you're just instead of a picture of
Dodie it's a picture of a cute little
otter
you're just the anonymous otter but
that's how Google Docs handles it it
like assigns you a random animal and you
got the best animal of all except
possibly armadillos thank you for being
a little otter on this episode of dear
Hank and John do you have a short poem
for us Rafi tee and I found this on it
on a page by itself and I thought it was
just one poem but it's actually the end
of it but I think it's perfect and it
sums up what I've been thinking about
recently okay so I read it yes please
okay nothing is too pure to avoid being
sliced away slowly by each passing
second there's a comfort in knowing that
there is an end to each elation and
tragedy there is an end and I think that
is the only thing we can be sure of very
dear Hank and John of you I think it was
really nice it's been it's like I've
been thinking a lot about how in about
time and like the happy moments I just
want to hold on to it because I'm like
no I don't want to end for this also
like appreciate it in the moment but
then also in the terrifying horrible
moments
indeed indeed well we now have to move
to questions from have to want to must
excitedly two questions from our
listeners I don't know there are so many
weird and great and also heartfelt and
scary and big ones I'm not even sure
where to start a guess I guess I'll
start with this first one from David who
asks dear Hank and Dodie I was
reminiscing the other day about my youth
and I came across a stunning realization
it's pretty troubling and I wonder if
you could shed some light on it
I could certainly understand why shadi
would wear the apple bottom jeans and
the boots with the fur especial
if she wanted to look nice at the club
however why would shawty wear apple
bottom jeans and the boots with the fur
and baggy sweatpants let alone the
Reeboks with the straps isn't this
overkill who in their right mind would
wear two sets of pants and two sets of
shoes does shorty have four legs is
shadi a centaur this would explain why
the whole club was quote looking at her
because centaurs don't frequent
nightclubs but if this is the case why
would she be called shoddy centaurs are
usually pretty tall and the explanation
would be helpful as this is completely
shaking my entire worldview sleepless
and disturbing David I don't know that
you've left any room for us to have a
good time David it seems like you
explored the bit pretty fully do you
happy yeah what are you what are you
thinking
look maybe they're cold maybe they
couldn't decide I change up my outfit
yeah maybe maybe she got maybe the jeans
got tight and she like so like between
that first section of the of the chorus
and the second section of the chorus
yeah she goes to the bathroom it changes
because the the yeah she wanted
something a little more comfortable and
so she changed into the baggy sweatpants
in the Reeboks with the straps just yeah
go ahead and google it I don't know if I
I don't know if I can tell you without
feeling like dirty man okay
they're like jeans that make your butt
look like an apple and sometimes they
actually have an apple on them I just
like interestingly one of the selections
so you know how when you go on Google
search and there's all the things that
are like extra you can add this search
term so it's like oh that wasn't what I
was looking for one of them is horse
so maybe horses do wear apple bottom
jeans no no this is a this is a meme
we're with the path where would it wear
the pants would it wear it like oh yeah
I know you're talking about the dog
wearing pants yes the there is it there
is a horse meme apple bottom jeans boots
with the fur and it is a furry footed
horse put it on the patreon for you so
everybody can see it
I clicked I clicked on horse apple
bottom jeans horse yeah there you see it
Wow
it's all so my question so I'm pretty
sure that shadi is not a centaur because
she turns around and she gives her big
booty a slap at one point in the song
and I don't know that a centaur could
reach their own butt yeah and that so
that unless like a just a really long
torso short horse parted centaur which
now that looks really weird in my yeah I
do like the M image of a centaur getting
low like just sort of like like sagging
down with the song until it's like got
its knees bent all the way is that its
friend is it both as all four legs or is
it just a back where its front legs are
it's like sitting up like it's a sitting
like a dog with the butt going I don't
know what's not
I feel weird about objectifying this
horse woman now good good I'm glad I've
done that to you do you want to ask
another question the person I have
thought I was going to spend the rest of
my life with recently decided that they
are just not in love with me anymore
I've mostly been dealing with this by
crying drinking and real listening to
all of their Hank and John any other
tips for dealing with heartbreak and
despair dissipation of the majority of
your future plans from Melissa Wow well
mmm
yes I've been thinking about
um you have yeah I the I have definitely
thought about this a lot in my life
luckily I haven't been thinking about it
a lot recently yeah but yes when when
there is this thing that you have like
this is the thing that I'm doing and
like here's the path that I'm on and
suddenly it's like sunk no you're not
yeah that must be so difficult it's a
lot to reconstruct because I've been
through breakups but there's never
really been that sort of this is it this
is my life this like massive plan ahead
of me so I can't imagine what that feels
like to have your timeline so I've
disrupted but there is a book that my
friends have lent me a few times and
it's called it's called a breakup
because it is broken and I think that
really kind of helps to like sum up
there is a reason for why this has
happened and if you can't find it yet
you will find it in time
but all I can say is and now it serves
yeah and as far as moving forward
sometimes it's impossible to but I in
the past have tried to do new things and
try new things and and like listen to
music I wouldn't have listened to before
and and do things I wouldn't have done
before which kind of gives me the
feeling of like oh well there are there
have always been infinite paths ahead of
me and there was never just one and and
and and now maybe I'm going to find one
that is different maybe it's better
maybe it's equally good maybe it's worse
but it is a path and and and like sort
of breaking the hold that the old path
had on me yeah and that's not in that
never had not a thing that you can do
immediately but as it is a thing that
comes and that you can you can with
intention sometimes speed along a little
bit yeah as soon as you start to sort of
get that closer from yourself and stop
the processing process this you know
you'll feel better and got that's gonna
be hard to do for a long time
Oh write a song about it - yeah that's
what Dodie does okay although a lot of
my friends say oh it's gonna be good for
your art when something has it is know
what you need yeah yeah this next
question is from anonymous actually at
the bottom says anonymous squirrel which
is interesting because we're here with
anonymous otter dear Hank and Dodie I've
been dating I've but no centaur is
completely anonymous everyone knows
scuffle song about her I've been dating
my boyfriend for over three years and
we're very happy I feel like bad
answering this question we're very happy
and my sorry and my family members now
regard him as part of our family I'd
never told my family that he and I met
on tinder frankly I wasn't even sure if
they knew what tinder was well recently
they've been making jokes about how they
think tinder is gross and creepy I've
just sat there awkwardly when they say
such things do I have an obligation to
tell them how we met
part of them feels like I'm keeping a
secret from them but another part of me
feels like it's necessary for them to
know especially if the Wow but another
part of me feels like it isn't necessary
for them to know especially if they have
already formed a negative impression of
the app do you think I should tell them
and if so how memento mori anonymous
squirrel I'm glad you're so anonymous
good otherwise I don't know does your
family listen to the father yeah and and
then they would they would know they
this is certainly not a situation other
people have ever been in I don't think
you have an obligation to tell them yeah
and I think that I think making fun of
tinder is a fun thing I think saying
it's creepy is another thing because
it's basically saying that like people
are put off by the idea of people
looking for relationships in a certain
way or looking for certain kinds of
relationships and that's a thing that we
do but it's a little bit discouraging
that it's something that your family
might do but tinder is a perfectly
legitimate way to meet someone and if
you like them
you to date them like it's not just yeah
it's it's yeah and you know like it's
easy to have a bad view of tinder if you
don't know very much about it just like
for the first two years that I was using
snapchat everybody was like who are you
sending nudes to and I'm like oh god
that's getting old yeah sort of
immediate reaction very happy
everything's all great yeah yeah just
yeah eventually someday because somebody
would be like like how did you meet and
you just say like Oh internet dating app
yeah dating service yeah or or you will
eventually come to embrace it and be
like tinder I thought we were just gonna
maybe smooch a little bit and it turned
out that we fell in love or maybe I was
there for love and I found it I don't
know I haven't used tinder I don't know
what it's like I'm old and I've been
married for decades it's definitely like
I know I have several friends who are
single and have internet audiences and
it can be a little weird to use dating
services that put your face on there
yeah you never know when people are
gonna be like ooh swipe that purse I
know that person from YouTube there's
this other app for quotation influences
but you have to get a reference for it
and what what there's an app for dating
internet people yeah or like influences
I think it's like for people with I
don't know for people oh you're freaking
joking with me there aren't enough
people I mean I guess I live in a small
town I know all the people who have
internet presences in my town it's like
me people that I work directly with and
this one guy who has a farm blog okay
yeah but I guess in London yeah yeah I
don't know already Connie to see like
all of my friends going have a reference
and it's not just like I'm lonely and
see if anyone listening has a reference
for the Moab do let me know be like you
get one oh my god lonely and
internet-famous
Oh God weird weird the world that we're
in like just funny that's a funny thing
but like the contrast yes hey I'm so
popular and not at all
please help pop you like can't get a
reference for the internet dating app
for people who oh man that's really oh
wow there's an app for everything I
guess
dear brothers of green I'm not a brother
of green but I hope they can help I have
trouble keeping conversations going and
recently I have tried to be better than
just letting the conversation fat off
and we both look at our phones do you
have any trusty conversation starters
you could lend to a novice like me panic
anxiety Mary yes how do you how do you
talk to people dirty Wow
well firstly put your phone away I've
noticed like whenever sometimes I talk
to friends their phone line up phone
lights up and immediately alike is like
oh you're not listening so if that
happens turn your phone over or put it
in your bag mm-hmm okay let me see
trusty conversation starters ah I have a
friend called Tom Rosenthal and he's
great at these you just have to be wacky
yeah ah
Oh my friend Sammy
okay my friendship group has a great way
to start conversation just play would
you rather but make it really weird okay
here's one here's one for you hmm
Hank would you rather would you rather
have a hand that is made entirely of
delicious ham and you can eat from it it
doesn't hurt you it's just never-ending
and it's just wonderful or would you
rather have an armpit that excretes
suncream and you can use it whenever you
need it
I mean you talk about these things as if
they're both pluses like would you
rather always have a delicious ham hand
or always have a ready supply of
sunscreen but I'm imagining it like well
first of all I don't want to not have a
hand like I need both of them I don't
want to have sunscreen this is such a
different question honestly like what
yeah generally some people like well
obviously this one is me this is there
you go here's the operation stop okay
welcome is my ham hand is my ham hand a
functioning hand like or is it just a
bunch of hands right so it doesn't have
like muscles in and it's not like so
yeah I wouldn't lose use of my hand just
so I could have ham all the time wait
could I wait Dodie did you say could I
could I solve world hunger with my ham
hand like is it that infinite could I
just like keep chopping and like there
would always be more ham okay well if it
grows ham and like an infinite rate and
I could actually feed the world with it
then maybe but otherwise I'd have to go
with sunscreen but I wouldn't like that
either
can we just know these are very good you
you've started a very good conversation
I have I have so I like at my age you
you end up with
distinct friend groups you know got my
friends from high school my friends from
college with my friends from work and my
friends from internet and friends from
up so I have a friend group that has
been having a like I don't know five six
year long conversation about whether
they would rather eat chocolate flavored
poop or poop flavored chocolate oh my
god and it like it whenever I see them
they're they're they're like okay
new modification to the chocolate
flavored poop question kind of like I
know that we've all got our positions
but what if we added an additional
condition like years have gone by and
and it has not been settled which would
you would you rather have it's like when
you eat those jelly beans that are
different flavors would you rather have
a vomit flavored jelly bean or jelly
bean flavored vomit I don't want to
vomit yeah we come out on different
different sides of this I would I would
rather eat chocolate flavored poop
because how would I even know the
difference there are so many different
textures of chocolate knowing it would
be knowing that that's what's happening
that would you know I kind of feel the
same way about black sausage that stuff
you have in a yeah like by pudding yes
like I will eat it and I'll be like this
is so delicious and I don't like it it's
just I just can't do it oh yeah I don't
have a problem with eggs they're not
like they're not like a baby animal I
don't know don't give me a heart don't
tell me don't tell me reasons to be
upset with with eggs because I love eggs
if you make me weird about them no no
I don't have a gots good life like
somehow I need to block that out well
there you go but yeah it is good to have
yeah it's good to have things like this
in your pocket another thing you can do
and this is totally sanctioned as long
as your friends don't listen to dear
Hank and John take one of the questions
from dear Hank and John and say like
make it a hypothetical or make it into
like something that your friend is going
through or like and be like like
hypothetically what would you do if and
then take this next question that I'm
about to ask about burritos because I
thought it was amazing it's from Logan
who asks dear Hank and Dodie I am 12 I
am composing a menu for my burrito bike
this is where I will go around town on a
bike that has a cooler on the back and
in the cooler will be burritos
I am currently trying to come up with a
menu what is this style of burritos that
you like example what do you like on
them what type of shell what type of
sauce what type of meat etc don't forget
to be awesome Logan so help me so like
now now everybody in the table is like
ok we got to help out this 12 year old
kid hypothetical 12 year old kid Logan
who is starting up his burrito bike
business which I love yeah I wish there
was a burrito bike in my town so I do
have a couple of questions for Logan one
is is the burrito cold or warm like it's
the cooler to keep them colder is it to
keep them warm cuz cooler can't keep
burritos warm but like I'm not totally
opposed to cold burritos right yeah you
like I mean I'm a little opposed because
I want to know that they're at the
temperature they're supposed to be at
and they haven't just been sitting there
for a day if I like it's like like pro
tip Logan not everyone's gonna trust you
because you're 12 and that's not no
fault of your own but like you got it
like you just haven't you don't know all
of the things that everybody knows so
people are gonna be a little skeptical
yes
[Music]
no don't know did you wash your hands
little buddy a dirty dirty little little
baker man I mean I I feel like maybe
going simple is the way to go and just
doing like like have it say like bean
and cheese burritos and there's this
there's a certain simplicity to that and
also like I don't necessarily like
there's not like when I like a really
good burrito is gonna have some hot
ingredients but that like but like re
microwaving a burrito one you're gonna
get it a little bit soggy too then
you're like the salsa and the guacamole
is hot and I kind of like for those
ingredients to be it they're like not
like soup like like salsa does shouldn't
necessarily be hot yeah so the yeah so
if it's gonna be reheated you got to
take that into account and then also I'm
thinking like maybe vegetarian just
because there's a little less chance of
food poisoning yeah for your burrito
bike but I love your entrepreneurial
go-getter attitude
Logan I miss being these things all seem
so possible and like why doesn't
everyone do this this is gonna be my
life now I'm gonna be a burrito biking
guy yeah well yeah I mean what if there
was just an army of burrito children who
were all over your town at any time and
you could just like push a button on
your app and they'd be there in like
three minutes
so you're saying ooh BRR but for food
Hank I think there might be a thing
that's called uber but for food I like
the idea of that being twelve a little
bit and I like the idea of like
eliminating the choice from it so
instead of being like I have to like
pick what restaurant I'm gonna get food
from it's just like like there's one
choice delivered to me a 400 calorie
bean and cheese burrito with some sauce
on it that's not gonna be great but it's
not gonna be bad but it's gonna be here
very fast and it's gonna be delivered by
a child named Logan who's helping to pay
for his
class trip to Louisiana let's write a
movie about it / make it happen
I like that I like making a movie about
it better once upon a time and this was
when I was after I had graduated from
college I thought why don't I start a
thing because I lived in Orlando Florida
where there's lots of traffic and the
stoplights at like I like areas where
there's like highway interchanges the
stoplights can be three or four minutes
long it's crazy like you just sit there
I was like why don't I just like set up
shop at one of those in sell people's
sandwiches and cokes
I'm pretty sure they it's illegal one
but in a second like it's also kind of
feels like the kind of thing that
somebody who doesn't have a biochemistry
degree would do with their time I don't
necessarily know that it would be like a
super lucrative enterprise but maybe
like ding ding cokes and cokes and
sandwiches ding ding and people just
stopped to be like Oh that'd be nice I
won't have to stop on the way home
faster and have a Coke or a coffee and
boom but instead I fly in my room and I
wanted to sleep with my friends Oh Jody
also is is strategically avoiding almost
the Latin sign offs that people are no
no I did cannot read that most I mean I
I just have to google them everybody is
being very yeah I think that means your
death my life oh wow which is like
something maybe soldiers say to each
other on the battlefield and I don't
know if she's talking to and honor to us
because hopefully to Anton a little
upset a good thing maybe us do you ever
feel abnormal amounts of empathy for
things that you normally wouldn't like
just the situation usually I mean yes
yes like for example has this funny joke
quite he'll he'll say look there's a
little rabbit on my hand and then
obviously my brain goes there's a rabbit
on Sammy's hand and feels a media
empathy towards this tiny little
imaginary creature and then he'll like
pretend to throw out on the floor or
something or like describe is horrible
death why is that so upsetting I that's
fascinating
like why play this game with your
friends why play this game and create
and make a sadness occur I usually don't
feel any empathy towards flies or bugs
especially spiders my goodness you never
know what like you you'll never want to
know what I've done the spiders but the
moment you name it you're like if I
called everything why I'm fine I I agree
I'd have to give them all burials and
sign off in Latin yeah no we I believe
we've had a question on to your Hank and
John before about like about be murder
and so it's not even new ground we're
treading here I feel like we still have
to explore it though because it's a
strange thing I occasionally this is
almost upsetting lead um occasionally
will like be walking down the street and
I'll kick a rock and then I'll kick the
rock again and then I'll kick the rock
like a fourth time and I'll be like well
now I'm kicking the rock now this is a
thing I'm doing and like okay and then I
like accidentally kick it into the grass
and I'll be like oh now I have to find
the rock
and so I like look for the rock and I
get the rock and like to be clear
there's a thousand other rocks around
every identical to the one that is but I
find the one that was my rock and I put
it back in the street and I start
kicking it and then I arrived at home
and I'm like well now I have a rock yeah
this is now my rock like I now have an
emotional connection to this rock and
I'm like like literally have several of
these rocks in a flower planter in the
back of my house you like well I can't
just get rid of you I'm connected to
this like I had a whole like and now I'm
not anymore like I could throw them away
now but like at the moment I can't just
like leave it in the road to some I'm
sure I've gone down and to others I've
gone up but but as for Anton Anton we've
got a die and one way or another and you
needed your swing Clara longer than
you'd think actually yeah like a month
yeah 28 days that's that's quite a long
time for a bug all right I wonder with
the longest like longest bug life
Internet how long can a bug live there
is at least one species of long-horned
beetle that beats out the cicada with
its ability to survive in larval form in
Deadwood for 35 to 50 years Wow
that's horrible that's a bug that lives
as low ah that's I this is good stuff
oh but oh there's more there's whoa okay
oh my can I just point out like the
moment anyone talks about bugs I feel
like my entire skin is crawling with
everything like I'm itching my elbow is
some well okay I just reading that I
just reading on this page that in fact
there are some termite queens that live
longer than 60 years what was that
little what was that little noise did
hear okay let's move on to another
question that's not about bugs make sure
they could sure this what is it about
bugs okay this one isn't about bugs this
one this one's good I think this is
interesting and I I think that we might
be good people to talk about it this
one's for many who asks dear Hank and
Dodie I need some help living as a human
as I think I've missed out on some
crucial instructive material
unfortunately I'm going to graduate from
uni soon and I'm not a go-getter not
like Logan selling burritos on the
street how do I succeed in life as an on
go getter there are classmates of mine
who are go-getters and it is clear they
are going to be successful Hank is a
go-getter and I understand that this is
the ideal way to live life I'm air
quoting now this is just what this
person is saying I'm not confident and
self-assured enough to put myself out
there and hunt opportunities down but
this is what I need to do or I can't be
a satisfactory people I am scared
I think my question is can I change my
ways is there a manual I can read on how
to put myself out there and hunt down
opportunities and sell burritos on the
streets I don't know if I can be an
artist if I continue to only do things
people say I should do are there any
careers that don't require go-getting
for success and a dubious advice would
be appreciated scared and confused and
memento mori mani I
so about this I thought you might like
I've want to start out by saying I
totally like the thing that you talked
about there in the middle mani where
where you just have done the things that
other people have told you to thus far
in life that was a hundred percent me
like until like my thirties no one is a
go-getter naturally I assure you if they
are except for Logan in his burritos oh
yes of course you live in life yeah like
pretty much honestly I think everyone
secretly thinks that they're lazy isn't
that like a name for that what is that
it's like there's like imposter syndrome
yeah it's like girl wins everyone do I
find out that I'm secretly the laziest
most incompetent person ever and yeah
yeah yeah I I literally have employees
whose job it is to tell me to do things
to like make me do stuff yeah and and
without them like I wouldn't wouldn't
and I by my secret yeah I would at this
point I would but like that took that
took me awhile and it took and it took
like a kind of insecurity to make me do
it now I wasn't a go-getter because I
was naturally a go-getter I think maybe
very much like many I was a go-getter
because I was afraid that like otherwise
I wouldn't be satisfactory people as
many puts it and but like you will you
will be satisfactory people without
being a go-getter the the like to me
what it like much more important and I
know that I say this from a place of
having had a lot of success that they've
like visible success and and less
visible failures that no one really
knows about it's not it's not so much
about the success it's about the success
that they're about the confidence that
success gives you or the confidence that
like like people knowing and saying good
things about you and for example saying
that I'm a go
here and and like that is not the only
way to get that confidence and finding
that security in yourself is really what
it's about and of course the first step
is to find security and like life and
food and shelter and in health care and
all that stuff but beyond that finding
security in who you and in it like
simultaneously with that stuff finding
security and who you are does not
require you to like to to like be Steve
Jobs yeah and and if you are thinking
that that in order to feel valuable and
feel confident that you have to like
match up with some imagined future you
or some some hero that you have which is
what I did for many years then what you
find is that you net you of course never
get there because because there's always
somebody who's more amazing than you are
like especially inside of your own mind
because that's what your mind is trying
to do it's trying to find like it's just
trying to find reasons that you're not
as valuable as you think as you are yeah
I don't know why but that is the thing
that brains do yeah yeah you said a lot
that's so true like I am definitely
guilty of comparison and the moment like
I was naturally lady I was definitely
like I am neither go-getter I am someone
who cannot like get up and do anything
but I did little things and then I got
praise from it people would go wow I
thought we were doing that why are you
working so hard and then my brain went
oh maybe I'm not lazy in the moment I
had that thought I wanted to do more and
then I defined myself as a go-getter
even though there's like this deep like
knowing that I'm actually you know that
kind of a peasant but I think you can
like you said you can find that many
ways yeah yeah a lot like a lot of the
ways that I've that like I think that I
have found it and then most people find
it is that they like sign up I get
signed up or they sign up for
responsibilities where people require
them to do
and do those things whether that's
taking care of a child or whether that's
little things and big things whether
that's doing the job that you have been
hired to do or helping a friend that you
you know care about and are loyal to
like all of these things are like the
opportunity to say like I have a
responsibility like to create the
responsibility and that's what gets you
out of bed yeah I think like it doesn't
like just like being then there are
people like this I think that they are
in the minority but there are people who
are just like get up and go and like
it's all about to them like doing like
get having the most productive day
possible because that's the thing that
that they love but for the rest of us
it's about signing up for
responsibilities and having to to
fulfill those responsibilities I think
which is which now is like Dodie and I
have both made the mistake of signing up
for too many responsibilities because
you're trying to how we have to undo it
this podcast Dodie it's time for a
sponsor's is brought to you by getting
out of bed in the morning getting out of
bed in the morning you don't do it
because you want to this podcast was
brought to you by Sammy's rabbit and all
of all of the Adam Todd's podcast is
additionally brought to you by ham hands
your hands are now made of hams and they
will solve world hunger by apple bottom
jeans which apparently makes your butt
look like an apple I think you have to
have a certain bottom tat to pull like I
don't think that I could have I'll have
a bottom that looked like an apple Dodie
thank you
either I am not ashamed of my butt at
all I think I have a fine but but still
let's do like I like one or two more
questions
before we get to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon if that's okay with you
yeah this question is from Mary who asks
dear Hank and Dodi but mostly Hank you
recently said on the pod that there are
nine missions on Mars right now which
got me thinking do any of the Rovers or
orbiters ever catch one another like do
we ever get an image back from an
orbiter in which a rover is like
randomly photobombing in the corner they
ever bump into each other
well I recognize I am completely
anthropomorphizing the robots crawling
around on Mars it's something that I
need to know desperately please help may
the force be with you Mary Wow
kind of definitely happens where and not
unintentionally but an orbiter will take
a picture of of a rover and and
sometimes it sometimes it just sort of
like happens to happen and other times
they're like we want to take a picture
and see where it's at and see if we can
make also take a picture of where its
parachute landed and stuff like that but
they are far enough away from each other
that they are not gonna run into each
other on the surface yet though the Mars
2020 mission sorry I'm bogarting this
question George I know that you wanna
tell us all about about Mars the Mars
2020 mission will have a thing where it
collects samples and then the idea is
that a future mission will land near
there and then go visit it and then pick
up those samples and then shoot the back
to earth potentially or it will be
visited by an actual human being who
will collect those samples so yeah if we
really nice it's like they were not all
alone for like forever yes I mean it's
funny cuz like the 2020 Rover will
literally beep like picking up rocks and
holding onto them but not for any
definite reason like maybe someday we'll
be able to go picked up those rocks but
but like mostly is just like I just
thought like I liked this one and I
really spend a lot of time with it so I
decided to keep it oh my gosh it's just
like that's me mr. Rover man yeah
Mars and that's there's there's a little
bit to do with that that I'm gonna talk
about in today's Mars news but before we
get to that one more question Dodie we
had so many good ones this week and we
got to a lot this was a really good
questions per episode rate for our dear
Hank and John I feel like last last time
we got to like three and dirty on hack
snapchat today he posted a video of the
movement activated sync that kept being
activated without there being anyone
doing so Hank's I made a joke about it
being a ghost with dirty hands bad jokes
aside this got me thinking would a ghost
theoretically be able to activate things
with movement sensors like some sinks or
those lights that turn on when someone
enters the room or would they not
recognize the ghost since these need a
is not technically made out of mass how
did movement sensors work do they apply
to ghosts so are they creatures made out
of mass only momentum it wasn't that
airport I was in an airport and it was
just like it didn't like it wasn't on
all the time it would just be like off
and then it would be like no it's like
what's that like what like it's okay if
you're like on and you're broken and
you're just on but if you're on and off
and on and off and nobody's standing
there like definitely a airport go
thanks Thank You Dodie the so first of
all I don't know that Tessa I don't know
a term that I like the Tess's just
assuming that ghosts have no mass I'd
like maybe they do maybe they maybe they
interact they seem to interact with
light some like the for the most part
stuff that interacts with light or can't
interact with anything has mass itself
so it seems like ghosts would have mass
unless there's some kind of
non-newtonian not non like Einsteinian
non like the standard model physics
happening here
but I do know how how the the sensors
work and and so it would depend on the
kind of ghost it was if it was a if it
was a hot ghost then it would work so
like I don't like so there's different
categories ago there's hot ghosts which
are like when they're in the room like
they'll touch you and it'll be like that
was a weird hot ghost hand and then
there's cold ghosts which like they give
you cold feelings and then there's wet
ghosts which will make you wet and then
there's like sand ghosts and they just
like leave sand around and then there's
there's just there's air ghosts that are
just sort of like collected air there's
there's pure pure water ghosts which are
made out of their only under water and
they're just like more dense water and
then there's fly ghosts which are made
out of a bunch of flies and so but so it
depends on the kind of ghost they are if
they're if they're a fly ghost
definitely like gonna activate that sink
but those motion-activated sinks are
actually not motion activated they're
heat activated so it would have to be a
hot a hot ghost maybe maybe it's because
your hands are cool I never thought
about that but I'm always like come on
do the thing like moving my hands around
even though it's not about the movement
it's about the heat so you actually want
to keep it up in front of there but it I
feel like if your hands are like room
temperature it's not gonna turn on and
you're like if you just happened to be a
cold person what a disaster so great
okay you don't you don't like fly ghosts
there's actually there's two kinds of
hot ghosts there's the ghosts that are
warm and then there's the ghosts that
are just very attractive Hey
oh man I just typed in AFC Wimbledon to
Google News because I know you didn't
bring any so let's see one hour ago we
got some some news about former AFC
Wimbledon and South End man joins his
good friend at Leatherhead so that
happened at some point in the history of
AFC Wimbledon have you ever noticed that
like the towns in your country or have
weird names excuse me where have weird
names just all when I was in London most
recently I was looking at the subway
stop so I was on the tube I was looking
at that stops the tube stops I guess oh
yeah and and all of the names of the
places where it was stopped like stopped
it was like a weird feeling of like
nostalgia because they all the I've
never heard of any of the places but
they all seemed like such English words
and I live in a place where we speak
English but a lot of the places are
named out of after things that are not
in English like they're named after
Spanish things or French things or
Native American words and like Montana
obviously is not a an English word it's
a Spanish word Florida the other state
that I'm from is a Spanish word Missoula
the city went from is a Native American
word so but like this weird like
connection to like oh these places were
named by people who have been like
living here living here from here like
not like came and conquered and like
took over this area and like got rid of
the people who were living here but
living here and all the places like that
like a weirdly like just the names of
the places made that more clear to me
and I just wanted to say that good I
always figure that's the number one
thing American people always talk about
when they come in
they're like it's oh oh that's so cool
yeah I'm just so used to you know seeing
a building this big about 500 years
older than that yeah yeah sure
well in in Mars news oh yeah
do let me know so you guys know that you
you guys you you Europeans I'm still
calling you Europeans in England for the
time being at least you had a Mars craft
that was headed to Mars and earlier like
last year in 2016 in October it it got
to Mars and then it just crashed into
the surface of Mars Oh sad sad face so
the the report of what happened has been
concluded and here's what happened so
when so these crafts have on them a
bunch of just like in your phone has a
bunch of accelerometers that will tell
you like what direction your phone is
facing so if you turn it sideways it's
like oh I know that I'm sideways now and
I'll take a sideways picture and they
also can kind of tell how fast they're
moving well do space probes obviously
have those as well so they could tell
how fast they're moving how fast they're
spinning whether they've stopped or
whether they're still moving and what
happened was a bunch of those
instruments got overloaded
when I think that craft is called the
Schiaparelli I don't know exactly how to
pronounce that the Schiaparelli at a
crucial moment for not very long for
like less than a second it's spun very
fast before it corrected itself and in
that moment when it was spinning very
quickly as it entered the Martian
atmosphere because just that's what
happens when you hit atmospheres
sometimes you spin and it's the it's for
example the reason why that guy who
jumped out of that red bull like space
balloon he pulled his ripcord early
because he started to spin and he was
spinning so fast that he you know if you
spend fast enough you will die so in a
in a similar way this thing was spinning
so fast that all of its instruments got
will
loaded and then suddenly it thought it
had landed already and it sent back a
report basically it was like I'm on the
surface of Mars and then it stopped
existing shortly thereafter and they
found a giant crater that hit had
crashed into so it thought it landed but
it was wrong and so it didn't do all the
things to prepare for landing and
instead just crashed so that's what
happened but the good news is the good
news is that she ever really while an
interesting and useful instrument a lot
of what it was doing was testing out to
see if the ESA is landing systems were
good enough to go on they're much more
expensive rover that they're sending in
2020 and we discovered that they weren't
so this problem will be fixed yeah handy
to know so that is the news from Mars
Dodie what did we learn today I learned
well I've never googled it before I've
heard of the many times but now I know
that it's just sort of big booties and
cheese
I learned that Dodie has friend Sammy
have I met Sammy you should he's great
okay well I hope that is great except
for the part where there's all the
rabbit murder yeah and and and we
learned that Hank we would not eat his
own hands he would he would feed the
world with them oh yeah
that you would give no it wasn't like I
don't believe that I could produce an
infant amount of ham from my hands like
I just don't accept it yes and yes
definitely at the same time like I would
prefer for that not to happen either
unless it was on demand like if it was
only when I wanted it to but if it was
just like whenever I sweat I sweated
sunscreen
no thank you sorry they're good thank
you for joining me on this episode of
dear Hank and John duty this podcast is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
Sheridan Gibson our social media person
is Victoria buongiorno Nicholas Jenkins
edge the podcast and our music is by the
great dinner Ola and as they say in our
hometown don't forget
[Music]